so this is a guy uh in the Army it's a
soldier leaving the service and
revealing how when he went to turn his
gear in he had to pay the government for
gear that was lost today is gear Turnin
day for
me turn in all the gear that I've
collected over the last four years of
being active duty with the army with the
82nd Airborne Division go to turn in my
gear they want to charge me $500 to
$1,000 for gear that I was ordered to
leave in Afghanistan two years ago
because as the last two birds were
sitting on the tarmac ready to leave
there wasn't any room for extra gear
extra weight therefore we were told to
leave it there's a lot of uh a lot of
comments to this people that were in the
military not at all surprised by this
and saying yeah this is what they do to
you those of us who do not serve it's
like actually surprising what do you
mean you have to pay they give you a
bill when you leave that you have to pay